uh what is russell crowe
what is russell crowe
excuse me i'm just that's gonna take
some time for me to think
hello i'm russell crowe and today i'm
taking the wired autocomplete
interview who is russell crowe
i've been wondering that a long time who
does russell crowe look like
well i've got uh good authority the
russell crowe
looks like mrs crowe's son very very
i mean so close it's uh a little crazy
actually
who russell crowe knitting i know what
this refers to
for many many years people in the
knitting fraternity have tried to enjoin
me
in their soft bosom and it comes from
a photo shoot i did in los angeles in
the early 90s
it was kind of a tedious shoot and the
dude had taken
forever setting up you know as they do
and then it was kind of like what are we
going to do we'd take a
shot sitting over there shot sitting
over there and at one point there was a
ball of wool and some knitting needles
so i did a half a dozen dozen shots like
that and they went out in that
particular magazine and they've been
used over and over
even though i'm kind of holding the
knitting needles incorrectly all that
sort of stuff
uh people like to make the association
that i'm a knitter so it's been
in continuous use now for some you know
close on 30 years as a concept and
here is the grand irony when i was a
child
i did knit my mother showed me this
skill so
that's how i know i was using the
needles incorrectly
what is russell crowe doing now well
currently i'm doing this interview but
in a broader sense in isolation
on a farm in northern new south wales
what am i doing now i'm getting up
really early in the morning
i start by doing stuff on email and then
when the sun's up we've been going out
and digging up some fields fertilizing
them
and re-seeding them but i'm writing
songs and i'm writing scripts and
it seems that i've actually been
practicing self-isolation for the best
part of the last 30 years
and i'm quite good at it what band was
russell crowe in the long answer to this
because
my first record came out in 1981 not
came out now it came out in 82
i was still a teenager i had a
performance um pseudonym
but after that i let's see go back to
first bands of profile
and then i was in a band by the name of
that
pseudonym then i was a band called bank
called roman antics and then for 20
something years i was in a band called
30 odd for the grunts then after 30 foot
of grunts
disbanded in 2003 i was in a band
called the ordinary fear of god i've
been collaborating with a fellow called
alan doyle on songwriting
since 2004. our current project is
called
igp indoor garden party and it refers to
in newfoundland which is where alan
comes from
they have kitchen parties and it's an
incredible cultural experience
a guitar will be brought out and it will
be basically passed around the room like
a talking stick
and every single person in the room has
a song
it's kind of like a piss take for me on
the weather pattern in newfoundland you
know
because alan at one point in time said
to me
that we also have garden parties and i'm
looking at the weather in newfoundland
and i thought it would be better to have
that garden party inside
anyway what did i win an oscar for i won
the oscar for the feature film
gladiator directed by ridley scott i
think the ceremony was 2001 but it's the
2000 oscar my zodiac sign
my zodiac sign is aries but in chinese
astrology my sign is a dragon and if you
put the two together
my primal astrological sign is a
tyrannosaurus rex
how about that now what car do i drive
currently my car is a mercedes
s600 v12 bit of a banger
you know what i'm saying yeah about 567
the odd british horsepower at my
disposal
to travel at 50 kilometers an hour
um where am i from i was born in new
zealand
in the city of wellington but my parents
migrated to australia when i was four
years old in 1968. and i've lived the
majority of my life in australia since
then
except for a seven year period where my
family returned to new zealand when i
was a teenager
where's my oscar reminds me of a funny
story
uh that al pacino told me he'd won the
oscar for
sin of a woman wasn't i'm not sure and
uh at the dorothy chandler pavilion
you get into an elevator and go from you
know the stage
level up to where the press gallery is
and so people are packed into this
elevator
the sardines and and al just looks down
and he realizes that
you know he's carrying his ward in his
hand just naturally this side
but the head of the oscar has actually
slipped between the cheeks uh
and the diaphanous dress of
the young lady who's standing in front
of him and so al
thinking he was doing the right thing
lent forward
and whispered in her ear that's not me
that's my oscar
al can tell a good story i'll tell you
that is russell crowe
british well um no born in new zealand
um live in australia but do have welsh
scottish and english and irish in the
background but also
norwegian italian and maori
is russell crowelli united fan yes i am
the english soccer team that i follow is
leeds united
currently not in the premiership haven't
been for quite some time
and that is a sensitive subject am i
left-handed
no i am not left-handed am i a nice guy
probably not am i russell crowe
related to cheryl crowe no and that uh
that should be obvious with the spelling
uh but also
i saw sure crow in the foyer
of a hotel and people had been making
that joke for so long
i just went up to her and said hi we're
supposed to be married
and thinking i was being charming and
you know apparently i wasn't
uh didn't go down very well how did
russell crowe become roger ailes
substantial amount of prosthetic makeup
a very
long and arduous thing to face every
work day
the fellow that did that makeup adrian
moreau is a
fantastic artist so oddly you would talk
about that
as being a torturous experience and
really the thought of it was and doing
it every day
was but uh he just made it very cool and
we got through it
very easily how old was russell crowe in
gladiator 20 years ago
today not today 20 years ago this year
gladiator came out we shot it in 1999 so
i was 35 when we shot it
and 36 when it came out
what is russell crowe what is
russell crowe excuse me i'm just
that's going to take some time for me to
think about
i'll um i'll text you an answer or
something okay
what color are my eyes well they're very
light and they take
light very well normally they're
actually
sort of a greeny hazely sort of thing
but in many movies they'll appear to be
blue
depends on what i'm wearing there has
been times when i've been at
customs traveling internationally where
the guy is looking at my face and
looking at
what it says on the piece of paper and
it two things didn't match
what school did russell crowe go to well
i went to many
ended up going to i think five primary
schools and three high schools
mainly just because my parents moved
around a lot what is my height
i'm what we call in australia a
collingwood six footer
i'm five foot eleven and a half and a
bit so
just shy of six foot a collingwood six
footer that refers to an australian
rules football team called collingwood
who made the super bowl of that
particular sport many many times
without winning it so possibly you would
call it a buffalo bills
six footer in america a russell crowe
and ryan gosling friends
well listen i tell you what i haven't
seen him for ages but that's the natural
cycle of time with actors but that kid
oh
i shouldn't really call him a kid but
that guy what an actor
his natural innate timing is just
breathtaking
when you're performing with him i'm
really good at keeping my
together on camera it doesn't matter if
the place is burning down
i'll still keep playing the character
and that's sort of been a
signature part of how i do my job you
know ryan gosling can make me laugh
in a heartbeat whatever character i'm
trying to do
he can just like a laser pump through it
and just it just sends me off
and there's lots of footage of behind
the scenes from nice guys
you know with the director calling out
ryan please
just let him say the dialogue this time
because i'm just pissing myself with
these ad-libs that he comes up with
so you know our connection is really
easy we get on we talk and i definitely
consider him a mate if he ever
you know called me or whatever needed
something you know totally i'd love to
do a second
film with him so great actor good bloke
ryan gosling
uh my latest movie that's coming out on
july 1st
is called unhinged before that there was
a thing on
showtime called the loudest voice which
you should see if you haven't
and unhinged you should definitely see
do i have siblings i have one older
brother his name
is terry can i sing my duties to the law
no can i ice skate i spent many many
months on the skill of ice skating for a
movie called mystery alaska back in 1998
and i reached the heady heights of the
skill and achievement
of that of your average canadian
seven-year-old though i would never ever
challenge one on the ice
did i do my own stunts in gladiator
pretty much
that was back when i had tendons of the
good old days
yeah i mean there's you know a part of
the functional move there's always going
to be people who are there to do those
sort of things for you
but when you're working with a director
like ridley you've got to give them 100
shot you know when you get a bit older
and your body starts to remind you of
all those takes when you didn't quite
get it right
and i'm not whinging i'm 56 it is what
it is i've used my body in
very extreme ways to make my living and
enjoy my life
and you do come to a point where you
pay for that but uh no regrets in that
regard at all
that's the end of our time for today and
i hope you can find something
special to do for the rest of your day
goodbye for now